hay algo profundamente satisfactorio en
abrir un sarcófago por primera vez
después de 2500 años
hay hermosas decoraciones en casi todas
partes afortunadamente para nosotros hay
mucho que superar 2020 fue un año
extraordinario para los egiptólogos con
más de 160 momias perfectamente selladas
encontradas debajo del cementerio de
saqqara
este año también vio una lluvia de
noticias sobre el espacio uno de los más
impresionantes fue el primer vuelo
espacial comercial tripulado la compañía
spacex comenzó a llevar astronautas a la
estación espacial internacional
brabo en un momento magnífico de la
historia de los vuelos espaciales y por
el comienzo de un nuevo viaje en algunos
casos los humanos ni siquiera son
necesarios los cerebros de las máquinas
demostraron ser más inteligentes que tus
nuestros gracias a alfa full the deep
mind la inteligencia artificial ahora
predice cómo las proteínas forman las
combinaciones que realizan las
principales funciones de la vida en el
futuro podríamos estar diseñando
nuestras propias proteínas pero ya
estamos jugando con lo que hay dentro de
ellas los genes emanuel serpentín
jennifer tuna recibieron el premio nobel
por desarrollar la edición del genoma
crisis' percas 9 una tecnología que
logró varios avances este año incluidos
los primeros ensayos clínicos para
modificar las células sanguíneas humanas
para que puedan combatir el cáncer
otros laboratorios han cocinado
literalmente la innovación el pollo
desarrollado en laboratorio debutó en
singapur en diciembre después de que el
país fuera el primero en permitir la
venta de carne elaborada sin sacrificar
animales